[Music]
honestly you know it's um quite
disturbing and and and and and
[Music]
15 plus 10. what's playing okay he's
1800 but
I definitely don't mind we have the
black pieces
good luck
E4
all right let's play E5 as we did in the
previous speedrun game which was the
Vienna I remind you
on that game we faced the Vienna and in
this game we might be facing the Vienna
again and I certainly don't mind that we
can put there there we go we can put my
recommendation to the test F4 this is
literally what we faced in the last game
I wonder if he actually saw the YouTube
video but I'm not shying away from this
we're gonna go D5 we're going for the
main line Knight takes C4 and I will
remind you that there is a fork in the
road in this position
the old move is Knight F3 that's what we
faced in the last Speed Run game the new
move is Queen F3 and this is what we're
facing right now does anybody know or
can anybody remember what my
recommendation was in this position and
there are two or three or even more
viable continuation so I'm not
pretending that this is the best line
but I think it's the most practical line
it's easy to learn and it essentially
guarantees an equal end game yeah the
move is Knight C6 exactly my move is
Knight C6
Bishop B5 is correct this move contains
a lot of Venom because Knight takes E4
runs into Knight D4 intermezza I'll show
that after the game but who can tell me
what my recommended continuation was
here Bishop B5 is correct how do we
actually get into the end game that I'm
mentioning yeah our opponent is booked
up so I'm presuming that our opponent
analyzed the end game we're about to get
more deeply than I did and in that case
we're just gonna have to improvise yeah
Knight takes C3
A6 is bad
because white simply takes on C6 and
then takes twice on e4 and wins upon the
move is Knight takes C3 DC and now a
maneuver that is quite common in the
Vienna
quite common in the Vienna we throw in a
check on H4 exploiting the drawback of
light not having a Pawn on F2 because
why I played F4 and we swing the queen
over to E4 we trade queens and we get
this end game and listen I have never
analyzed this end game that deeply I
know for a fact that it's equal I have
run stockfish at a very high depth in
the send game I know for a fact that the
computer basically gives zeros uh it's
but it's Dynamic equality it's not
equality because the position is
symmetrical it's not symmetrical we both
have weaknesses on E5 and E4 usually the
pawns are reversed so it takes a second
to adjust your eyes to this position
normally white spawn is on e4 and black
spawn is on E5 here it's the opposite so
that's what makes this position a little
bit weird and we almost have a race of
of who can get to their respective
weakness faster what do we have going
for us well we have going for us is a
not even really a lead in development
but the pod on e4 is restricting the
development of white Snider it's not
allowing Knight F3 so of course why can
go 92 but developing the Knight to E2 is
a lot less effective here and from E2
the Knight doesn't have that many
prospects the G3 Square which would be
perfect for the knight in terms of
attacking E4 is already occupied by a
pawn
so white is having some problems
figuring out a good spot for his Knight
conversely we also have some issues with
our development and the ball right now
is in White's court and the decision
that white has to make straight away is
whether they take on C6 here or keep the
two Bishops on the board so white can go
Bishop F4 Knight E2 these types of moves
or White can trade on C6 which has the
effect of ruining Black's Queen Side
Pawn structure but on the other hand it
gives black the bishop pair and it gives
us a monopoly on the light squares why
are the light squares important here
where hopefully you can see why they're
important or how they could be important
look at all these squares these squares
are easily accessible to our Bishop and
they're quite weak and why are they weak
because white played this move G3 we can
also entrench our Bishop on D5 or after
Bishop takes C6 B take C6 we have an
additional pathway that has opened up to
A6 which can be a a pretty enticing
Square as well
full disclosure I don't remember what
White's best move is here I've had this
a couple of times in my Blitz Games I do
not recall what the computer
recommendation here is for white so
we're basically on our own this time our
opponent has gone for the topical line
and he plays Bishop to E3 okay so that's
a pretty sensible developing move
but the drawback of not taking on C6
what is the drawback of white not taking
on C6 well we can try to make white
regret it how can we try to make white
regret not taking on C6 immediately
we can now play them with Bishop D7 not
because the pin is so dangerous to our
survival but because now if white takes
on C6 we take back and not only do we
have the bishop pair but also our Pawn
structure is fully intact and I think
there we could start maybe contending
for uh a tiny tiny Edge although I still
think it's it's probably dead equal
after the trade on C6 because we don't
have uh the Machinery to attack the e59
the Knight is an integral attacker here
and if it's traded it's going to be
harder for us to attack the pawn on E5
approaching it with the Bishops is quite
difficult in a game between two GMS this
would be
Mo this would most likely end in a draw
most games like one way or the other the
position would fizzle out but you know
at lower levels there's plenty of life
in this position not just a comment a
couple comments in the YouTube channel
the last couple of speedrun games have
been they've been more positional we
switched this 15 plus 10 time control
and at times I understand that it can be
a little bit maybe boring is the wrong
word but it can be a grind to listen to
me explaining you know positional
subtleties in some end game that is
totally devoid of tactics but I maintain
that if you want to build yourself up as
a tactical player you have to take care
of the fundamentals you have to know how
to play boring end games you have to
know how to win them
um and how to squeeze advantages out of
equal positions right you can't always
get the types of positions you want to
get so think of it if you're kind of
feeling down that we keep getting these
end games think of it as making an
investment into your chess future taking
care of the fundamentals is going to
help you develop your style more
effectively whether you're a tactical or
positionally minded player doesn't
matter
it's like eating your veggies so what is
our opponent thinking about what are we
threatening well we're threatening to
take the pond with our Knight we are
threatening Knight takes E5 my guess is
that our opponent is
probably unwilling to take on C6 he
probably realizes that
he should have done so on the previous
move if he wants to trade but obviously
if you're comparing losing the center
Pawn to trading the bishop for the night
you should go for the ladder and he does
Bishop takes Bishop takes
and now we still need to complete our
development by which I mean we need to
figure out lodging
lodging for the king and we need to
determine where we want to put this
bishop so I think some of you
might be quite tempted and I'm not
rolling this option out by the way
some of you might be tempted by the move
G6 fiancadoing the bishop has the
obvious benefit of immediately attacking
the E5 Pawn the drawback of the move G6
is that it's a little slower uh and we
might get stuck with our King in the
center or white might develop some sort
of initiative so let's try to calculate
if we play G6
what is white likely to do well I think
White's probably likely to develop his
Knight let's say g692 leafy and ketto
are Bishop to G7 attacking the pawn and
E5
and white will probably have to defend
that pawn with his Bishop so Bishop D4
or Bishop F4
but the good thing about Bishop D4 is
that it closes down the D file which
means we can then castle queenside if we
wanted to we can also Castle kingside
nothing wrong with that
so let's compare that to Bishop E7 do we
prefer
spending two Tempe and putting the
bishop on G7 or spending one tempo and
getting our development done well it's
it's a judgment call it's an intuitive
judgment call I have a preference I
think we should play more ambitiously
here and the reason I think so is
because the Queens are off the board
the Queens are off the board I don't
think our King is in any imminent danger
I don't think there's anything white can
really do on the D file so quality of
development in this particular instance
is more important than speed of
development and so let's go for G6
I think this is a more challenging move
hopefully that logic makes sense to you
we want to go G6 Bishop G7
attacking the pawn on E5 and additional
subtlety is that moving the bishop
immediately A Move Like Bishop D4 I
think might be tempting to a lot of
people is a huge blunder
notice that our Bishop x-rays the rook
and E3 is not only a discovered attack
but it simply traps The Rook in the
corner if the Knight isn't developed
first
foreign
and he does 92 very good
okay we continue with our
approach Bishop G7
and we toss the ball back into White's
Court White has in my mind two obvious
candidate moves Bishop F4 Bishop D4 both
of them have their pluses and minuses
important to point out that in response
to either of them E3 already loses its
luster it just turns the pawn into a
Sitting Duck and it doesn't trap The
Rook anymore The Rook has the E1 Square
so we're going to keep our Pawn on e4
firmly we're going to try to keep it
protected by the bishop
all right
so my opponent by the way wrote me that
he he's a big fan of the stream and he's
got the stream on mute right now so
no reason to distrust him
um Bishop F4 versus Bishop D4
is what we're what we're waiting for now
if white plays Bishop f for
then obviously it would be illegal to
Castle queenside we would
probably have to either Castle King said
we could also keep our King in the
center but with both of the Rooks and
two minor pieces still on the board I
would be a little bit hesitant to keep
the king in the center I think the king
could end up getting caught in the
crossfire so Bishop F4 Castle short the
Knight is probably going to jump into D4
but when the Knight jumps into D4 we can
slide our Bishop up to D5 classic idea
right in moving to D4 white closes off
the D file what we want to avoid is a
trade of the night for the bishop the
only circumstance under which we would
allow this trade is if we would be
winning the E5 Pawn by force but
allowing this trade without any reason
leaves the E4 Pawn once again as a
Sitting Duck
so in response to Knight D4 we probably
want to play Bishop D5 or maybe even
Bishop D7
B con B con asks is E6 an option here
for white
classic idea right you go E6 you
sacrifice a pawn in order to permanently
uh ruin the Integrity of Black's King
Side Pawn structure yeah E6 is
definitely possible but I think we're
gonna be happy to gobble the pawn up
yeah we're gonna have doubled e pawns
but a past an extra Pawn is still an
extra pawn and this is an end game so
giving pawns up like this in an end game
is a very dangerous road to go on
also after E6 we should definitely
consider F5 as dangerous as that move it
looks it builds up a pawn chain the pawn
on E6 is pretty weak so we'll cross that
bridge if we get there our opponent
taking his time
why is this an end game well the Queens
are off the board and two sets of miners
are off the board so I think this is
sort of borderline queenless middle game
I think with an additional pair of
miners on the board I would call it an
end game as it stands I think it's sorry
I would call it a queenless middle game
as it stands I think we're in end game
territory okay Knight D4 that's a big
move I was not expecting that
so what did I say about allowing the
trade of Knight for Bishop we allow it
only in one circumstance
in circumstance being we pick up the
pawn and E5 and we have the option of
playing Bishop takes E5 let's calculate
our opponent clearly has something up
his sleeve
hmm what could it be I think I know what
it is so Bishop takes C5 I think he
wants to take B take C6 and probably our
opponent is attracted to this move by
the fact that as a bonus our Pawn
structure is ruined but we get a four on
two on the other side of the board so
takes takes takes I think he wants to
move Bishop D4
in that resulting position
so if you're watching this on YouTube
and you're losing track you can set this
up on your own board and follow along or
you can wait until after the game and
I'll make these moves on the board so
here's what I'm calculating Bishop takes
E5 Knight takes C6 BC Bishop slides up
to D4 forcing the bishop trade
we trade now what move should we play in
that position testing everyone's
visualization after Bishop takes D4 Rook
takes D4
what is black obliged to do we should go
F5
we should go F5 to defend E4 and in that
position I think our opponent wants to
double on the D file and try to
infiltrate the seventh Rank and I think
he believes that offers him sufficient
compensation for the pawn
now I actually think the compensation
there is insufficient and it's
insufficient because we have the
possibility of creating connected
passers in the center with what
technique who can tell me how black can
make another past Pawn
this is after we take on E5 in addition
to the Past epon what technique is
available to us later on down the line
not h5h4
yeah G5 F4 so if you if the pawn is gone
from E5 G5 F5 F4 creates a set of
connected and protected passers deep in
White's territory I think that's going
to give us enough Mobility uh and that's
such a huge trump card I would be happy
to give up all of our Queen side pawns
just for that let's take on E5
let's take on E5 again if you didn't
follow all of it or if you follow 10 of
that don't panic that is why we look at
the games after they're played so I can
make the moves on the board and
re-explain the high level uh thought
processes but
this is just life at this level right
you got to calculate high level
variations that's just what you got to
do okay Knight C6 on the board we take
back
it's important that you don't feel
embarrassed if you're not visualizing
this when I was 800 I wouldn't be able
to visualize this line either just be
patient with yourself and you know try
to extract whatever you can extract
during the game and then
you know that's why I let people ask
questions so that you can get the
clarification you need after the game
I was 800 once believe it or not I would
say this is analysis at the level of
maybe two thousand twenty one hundred so
we're in pretty serious territory m2200
Plus
and uh I'm trying to raise my thinking
to the level that corresponds with our
current rating in the Speedrome that's
the entire premise of the speedrun
anyways
how old was I yeah maybe I think I was
seven my first rating was 808 USCF
rating was 800 803.
I remember that very clearly it was 803
after my first tournament
born as a 1600 yeah that was my default
rating at Birth
yeah what's funny is after the speed run
um maybe we can even put this in the
speed on video
I can actually show you guys I haven't
recorded and when I'm in San Francisco I
sometimes show you my initial score
sheets from my very first games there is
a website that has some of my early
games from when I was like a thousand
maybe I'll try to find them but let's
get back to the game because we have an
important decision to make bishop C5 is
on the board so I was wrong our opponent
does not play Bishop D4 he keeps our
Bishop alive
and instead the idea of this move is
very obvious it is aimed at preventing
us from castling and we can't Castle
queenside now because of the Rook can't
Castle kingside because of Bishop C5
so we don't need to panic here and we
certainly don't need to play Bishop D6
we we don't need to Castle on the next
move what is Mission critical is to
ensure that this Pawn on e4 is protected
this Pawn is what's going to win us the
game if we keep it intact it's what's
going to lose us the game if this Pawn
drops so to me the correct move here is
basically a no-brainer we play F5 first
order of business to build up the pawn
chain and secure our our Loot on e4
then we think
now the added benefit of the move F5 is
that we have opened up a little pathway
for our King remember this is an end
game so you're under no obligation to
Castle King F7 King E6 would be an ideal
placement for the king it's on a light
Square it can't be bothered and it
protects the D7 Square the problem is
that if we play King F7 we will have to
reckon with the check on D7
which is actually not such a dangerous
check because the C7 Pawn is protected
it's kind of a dead end we could play
King F7 Rook D7 check and still go King
E6
and if white goes Rook E7 check we can
slide the king over to F6 and ultimately
smoke this Rook out of there with our
own Rooks so that would be one way to
continue but it all depends on what
white does here
another option is of course for us to
play Rook d8
what is the drawback of the move Rook d8
who can tell me like Rook d8 would be an
ideal move trading a pair of Rooks with
every trade the value of our Pawn
majority grows
but what's the problem with Rook to you
what's the hole the hole is that it
hangs A7 why is it important that is A7
an important pawn it is a very important
Pawn we do not the last thing we want to
give white is an outside pass Pawn on A2
that is the greatest asset you could
have in an end game like this is an
outside passer
so one idea that I'm coming up with is
to just play A6
right just move the pawn out of the way
of the bishop and then we play Rook d8
given to Tempe
so what worries me here is a move like
Rook D2
that would be a very smart move because
in response to A6 white would double on
the D file and we would
you know the ship will have sailed we
won't be able to play Rook d8
why not A5
the reason is very simple A5 puts the
pawn on a dark Square where it can
hypothetically be attacked by White's
Bishop after A5 white can respond with
A4 to fix the pawn on a dark square and
that's going to be a headache that's
going to last us the rest of the game
also after A5 A4 white has a much easier
job creating a past Pawn with b2b4 right
you want to make it as difficult as
possible you want to make it impossible
for white to create a passer on the
queen side and amazingly
this Pawn formation I've talked about
this before this Pawn formation as ugly
as it looks it actually does an amazing
job of holding back White's Pawn
majority if we put our Pawn on A6 it's
like spikes you know it's like when
vampires were buried
um I've made this analogy before they
would saw this on some History Channel
show they would bury them with spikes
around the gray so that when they Rose
from the grave they'd get impaled and
these are like the spikes that are
preventing White's pawns from
progressing past B5 if that makes sense
I don't know why I that stuck out to me
yes uh spooky concept
but you get what I'm saying right these
are like the spikes and I guess White's
pawns are like the vampire
okay just roll with it just roll with it
yeah you definitely do that when you
want to bury a vampire scissors Polaris
on The Daily yeah our opponent is taking
his sweet time King B1 okay King B1 is
that's a bad move I I really don't
understand that but that gives us a free
tempo
it gives us a free tempo
what is the
sort of top thing that we want to do
with the free Tempo I think we can play
either King F7 or A6 I think either of
these two moves is
is good
um let me think for a second
I think both moves are good
I think both moves are
are perfectly fine
but let's let's let's play A6
let's play A6 I think given this extra
tempo
we can just and and by the way even if
we don't end up playing Rook d8 A6 is
still a good move to play because we
just remove the headache of having to
constantly worry about the pawn being
hanging if we move the Rook away from it
at a later Point Rook D2
okay but now this comes a little bit too
late because what move can we now get in
what move can we now get and what was
the actual point of A6 why does trying
to double Rooks but we beat him to the
punch Rook da there it is
of course white can still double
but a trait of Rooks here is
deathly bad for white because one Rook
is just not going to be able to deal
with uh the the strain of Black's
doubled passers
we're just gonna trade Rooks and then
play basically play G5 F4 at the first
available opportunity and we're gonna
win trade okay but if we play G5
prematurely we run the risk of the pawns
becoming a runaway train so we don't
want to play G5 until we're ready to do
so
and I think that there's no hurry to
play G5 we can always make this move I
think we should begin
by um improving our position
I think we should begin by improving our
position
and how do we improve our position well
I think King F7 is a very enticing move
indeed
I thinking F7 is a very enticing move
indeed after King F7 Rook D7 check
there's a very important tactical
subtlety we have to avoid playing King
E6 in that position it would be a huge
blunter
I'll get to that if it happens so after
Rook D7 check we have to go up to F6 and
once the king is up to F6 then we are
finally ready to play G5 and F4 notice
how good of a job the bishop is doing
covering the C7 pawn and restricting
lights Rook from accessing the queen
side
yeah so those of you who are tactically
minded you might spot the trick Rook D7
King E6 Rook E7 check always have to
think about tactics no matter how many
pieces are left on the board then Rook
takes E5 check and Bishop D4 skewering
the king to the rook and white is able
in that position final position to stop
the epon with his King
very good
no this is completely winning this is a
not just an extra Pawn but this is this
plan is totally devastating White's
gonna end up having to give up an entire
Bishop
to to deal with the if that if he even
manages that which is not a given
which is not a given
now my opponent mentioned that he
watches the stream so I'm going to want
to ask him like uh I'm I'm pretty
weirded out about Knight D4
like why give up a pawn and my guess is
that he thought in this position
that and maybe some of you can give me
an insight into you know like the 1800
mind
I have a feeling and we'll talk more
about this after the game that he
thought okay the King has totally cut
off and these ideas of going around the
barriers can be hard to spot
so we'll talk about this in more detail
after we finish
the technical task I can't believe it's
only been 20 moves
yeah this Pawn chain you can stare at
forever
yeah no this is over this is over we're
just gonna play G5 F4 E3 and we're gonna
build up a new pawn chain and we're just
gonna keep sliding that pawn chain up
until we promote Bishop E3 okay that's
actually not a bad move
and it does prevent G5
fortunately we can play H6 whenever we
need to play it
we can play H6 whenever we need to
notice that Rook D7 check now we can
play King E6 and it simply chases The
Rook off of the seventh rank let's go H6
let's prepare G5 and let's get down to
business H4 blunders the G3 Pawn so
white is powerless against the move G5
of course Rook F2 white could start with
but then we play King E6 that is why
it's so important to involve our King in
any such effort okay let's get down to
business to defeat the Huns G5
why not Bishop D6 because it's
unnecessary we don't need to stop Rook
d67 check because we move the king up to
E6 and now the Rook simply has to leave
the seventh rank
and now the key move right King E6 this
is why we went King F7 here in order to
be able to support the temporarily weak
F5 Fawn with King E6 that's why it's so
important to be patient in the end game
you know what the idea is but you
improve your position to the maximum
first how should we proceed
how should we proceed
just keep it simple we want to prepare a
four
we want to go to the Moon not because it
is easy but because it is hard Rook not
d8 we can play Rook d8
but again we're
focusing on just winning this game as
quickly as we can or Cafe it is
on the board
okay C3
and of course we are ready to play F4
and push our
beautiful
connected
past Pawns
do you have GF of course we don't want
to take with a bishop here although we
could we could take with the bishop and
it would still be completely winning
but um
we will instead take with a pawn
Bishop D4
Okay so
in such positions you don't want to like
immediately rush to exchange pieces you
want to be very purposeful about
exchanging and you should only exchange
if you've calculated until the end here
I think the easiest is actually do not
play E3 because in blunders Bishop takes
E3 and suddenly white is back in the
game The Rook is undefended
I think the best and most efficient way
to win is indeed to take the pawn now
should we play F3 or should we play E3
one of these moves is very very bad
of course we should play E3 if you play
F3 you create a hole on E3 that white
could fill with his King now it's going
to take us 50 years to get the king out
of there so we play E3 now
you might say but doesn't this create a
hole on F3 it does that hole can be
occupied by The Rook but the Rook is a
much easier piece to smoke out of a
particular Square we can use our King
for that King F5 and King E4 is going to
end the game
and then if white brings the king up to
E2 we can use our Rook to then dislodge
the king via the G file let's go King F5
I'm anticipating King D1 here this is a
very sort of traditional method go King
E4 what is going to go King E2
and then we use the open files as an
Avenue we get the Rook to G2 and that
ends the game that's the straw that
breaks White's resistance
yeah so notice that Rook Rook B8 here is
inferior Rook B8 runs into B3 so we
literally have only one file that we can
do this through we do it through the G
file
Rook G8 and Rook G2
white has to move his Rook their Rook
then we go Rook GT three uh Rook G2 and
we push the pawn to F3 if you want to be
fancy here we can start with F3 let's be
fancy start with F3
Rook takes F3 and Rook G to check
forcing the king back we win The Rook we
win the game GG
let's take a look
yeah so again you might look at this and
say well that was kind of disappointing
there were no tactics it wasn't that
interesting in the game let's be real
but not interesting and not instructive
are two completely different things if
you're 21 to if you want to get to the
level of you know two thousand twenty
one hundred standard you have to be
comfortable winning games like this you
know just squeezing out a equal end game
exploiting a mistake and then pouncing
in uncompromising fashion
let's go over it quickly
all right so I know
and our opponent told me that this is
all in Levy's course Levy of course
analyzes 926 I remind you that Knight
takes C4 is a very common trap black has
Knight D4 and white is already in huge
trouble
because if you try to cling to the pawn
if you try to cling to the pawn then
black plays Bishop F5 with devastating
attack on C2
GG and I'm going to be asking you some
questions
Maybe
Conrad excellent win H4 check G3 Queen
e468 so I assume Bishop E3 is in Levy's
course as well I see that it is the top
engine mode Bishop D7
and here you correctly took on C6 of
course you certainly don't want to give
up the pawn on E5 the Trap that I
outlined uh in the last video If white
plays Bishop F4 Bishop D7 and that says
okay we're safe the pawn is protected uh
you're running into these ideas like
Knight takes E5
Maybe not immediately not here but after
a preliminary Castle Queen side Knight
takes E5 is still a threat because of
the the classic motif
so Bishop E3 Bishop D7 trade I think is
totally fine castles
and we go G6 here hopefully the logic
uh of why we chose to develop the bishop
here makes sense 92 Bishop G7
Knight T4
okay so Knight D4 is actually very very
interesting I think that the key mistake
was not Knight D4 I think after Bishop
D4 white should probably have enough
counter play to make a draw but it is
incredibly difficult uh to handle these
types of positions we'll get to that in
a moment
we'll get to that in a moment I think
the simplest Conrad would have been to
play Bishop F4
and I think Bishop F4 is much stronger
than Bishop D4 because on D4 the bishop
is clogging the coordination of White's
pieces now you can bring the Knight to
D4 now you don't have the D file here
black simply castles plays Rook FEA when
we pick up the pawn bishop F4 I think is
the best move practically speaking
um we would have castled
and probably white should go Knight D4
at this point
and it occurred to me that if we play
Bishop D5 I white can bring the Rook
into the game
and black experiences uh a good amount
of tactical problems here because if we
just go after the pawn this is a big
blunder because of the move Knight B5
attacking the bishop attacking C7 we're
losing material
so you might say well no problem let's
just go A6
but A6 doesn't actually stop Knight B5
you know white can play a random move
like A3 and Rook f8 again runs into
Knight P5 takes takes the pawn is
protected and if we play C6 The Rook
drives into D7 I don't think white is
worse here it's probably equal
so if we rewind after Bishop F4
probably it is a good idea for black to
throw in the moves h6h4 because H4 is a
slightly weakening move we probably
would have canceled now
and in this position I think the best
approach for black is not to play Bishop
D5 but to drop the bishop to D7 and one
of the benefits of inducing H4 comes out
here the fact that the bishop does have
a nice little stronghold on G4
I think this end game if you turn on the
engine will probably show us equal
something around equal it's dynamically
balanced both sides have pretty good
chances here it's just complicated why
not F6 instead of H6 asks Jackson F6 is
a bad move because you're helping your
opponent eradicate the weakness for free
you're trading off the weakness uh and
in addition you're blundering the pawn
on C7
so the point of H6 is to play G5
dislodging the Bishop from F4 we're just
trying to go after this Pawn
and we're inducing a weakening move a
move that weakens the light squares even
further
so
Conrad you decided to sacrifice the pawn
which is a very interesting decision
Bishop C5 I think is a very serious
mistake this is a myopic move because
you're trying to prevent the black king
from moving but you don't have the
Machinery to be able to do that after F5
it's very easy to go around this with
King F7 and King E6
so I feel very strongly that Bishop D4
was the best chance here for white let's
analyze this end game
Bishop takes D4 Rook takes D4
um martos asks another interesting
question before we analyze this why
doesn't white play E6 and trade the
e-pawn for the C Pawn okay let's rewind
so you were asking why doesn't white go
Bishop F4 H6
and E6 interesting question I think the
explanation is going to be quite deep E6
I think is not a bad move but after F
takes e66 Bishop takes E7 what has been
the result of this trade yes you have
optically ruined black structure but you
have given me the f file what can we do
with the f file well Rook F2 is a big
threat E3 and Rook F2 is a big threat
black suddenly gets a lot of dynamic
counter play and what's really
interesting is that now if white plays
Knight D4 which move looks a heck of a
lot better than it did without uh White
playing E6 who can tell me where the
bishop should go in this position I
remind you after H6 H4 castles Knight D4
here we dropped the bishop back to D7
but after e-sync's Fe we suddenly have a
hidden benefit we can play Bishop D5 and
the pawn on E6 defends the bishop which
means there's no tactics related to a
discovered attack against the bishop
notice how the bishop put protects both
of these pawns very securely and because
they're on light squares they're going
to be very very difficult to attack one
more time
so this is a good example of a line in
which
factors in which what you might see if
you look at this for a couple of seconds
is the bad Pawn structure but there's
additional benefits the black gains from
this trade which might not be as evident
is B3 C4 not a problem
um
yeah B3 is possible but I think
concretely black is okay Rook ac8
skewers the bishop to the pawn
yeah but I don't think you're actually
going to be able to play B3 I don't
think you're actually going to be able
to play B3 Rook ac-8 you're probably
going to go Bishop D6
but I can even I can probably do this
thing where I go Rook F2
C4 oh and I just confirmed this with the
engine black is a brilliant move here
find pause the video if you're on
watching this on YouTube and find
Black's move this shows us that you
should never forget about tactics in the
end game and you have enough pieces here
to be able to deliver Checkmate for
black
you break through there's a bishop
there's a rook on the second there's
another Rook on C8 that is just itching
to join the action and you join the
action by crashing through the C file
Bishop takes C4 and Rook takes C4 and
this is crushing for black
and it's not such a crazy sack you
already have two pawns for the piece but
also the Knight is hanging the night is
hanging cannot be defended and if you
move the Knight you get massacred on the
second rank this is just checkmate
this is just checkmate
Rook C2
or or King A1 Rook takes B3 with a
discovered mate
so
yeah some high level lines here
but you can see the black's position is
quite dynamically you know there's it's
full of full of energy right you have
the capacity to meet whatever white
throws at you so Knight D4 Bishop B5
let's get back to Bishop D4 which would
have been the best move
trade F5 and Rook HD1 so this position
is very difficult to evaluate because
black is up a pawn it's a big Pawn but
white has full control of the only open
file in the position which as I've said
many times is a pretty big deal so
here's what I was calculating here
during the game
how do we meet Rook D7 well we can't
prevent white from getting to D7 so we
have to try to take this thing out of it
how do we take the sting out of a rook
appearing on the seventh rank Well
normally the prescribed method is to
engineer a situation where you're able
to put your own Rook on the seventh rank
to smoke your opponent's Rook out you
can do this in two ways you can castle
and then meet Rook D7 with Rook F7
how does the line continue well white
can trade one pair of Rooks and then put
the other Rook on the seventh Rank and
here you get a crazy end game that I
think black has to be better here
because yes white is grabbing all of
these Pawns but black can play the move
rook d8 and cut the king off prevent it
from Ever Getting to D2 again
and even though at this point black is
down upon look at these past spawns
You're Gonna Go F4 and E3 and you're
just going to easily promote the epon
the passers are totally deadly here it
should make sense to you that black is
winning in this position and I just
confirmed to the engine black is winning
in this position
according to the engine in this position
this is so instructive
who can tell me what White's best move
is it's not Rook takes C7 it's not Rook
takes H7 what does white absolutely need
to do to give himself a chance of
stopping Black's passers bring the king
into D2 patience
black plays G5
and now you go King E3 you need to use
your king to try to stop black from
playing F4 unfortunately for white it
looks like black is still winning here
rookie 8 is the computer move
and if Rook takes C7 black wins with a
very pretty tactic F4
take take take E3 and amazingly the pawn
is Unstoppable you're at this point up a
million pawns but the king just hides
away on h8 and you're just gonna go E2
and E1 white is not in time again Rook
behind pass Pawn
so
my guess
is that white probably has some way to
hold the draw here
but if we were to reason in Practical
terms the decisive mistake I think
actually is giving up the C5 Pawn giving
black
the four on two pod majority on the king
side just makes it so difficult for
white to defend because it's such a
simple idea F5 G5 and F4 you're just
pushing your pawns like a monkey
so
Bishop C5 I think exacerbates the
situation after F5 I think the black is
almost already winning
King B1 Conrad I really didn't
understand I think this this is just a
waste of a move I mean if I were you I
would at least maybe try to bring the
Rook into the game
and and try to make it more difficult
for black to uh to do what he wants to
do I also was a little bit worried about
Rook D2
here if black plays A6 you are able to
double Rooks in time to prevent Rook d8
so after Rook D2 We would have played
King F7 no maybe you can try Rook D7
chick you can try to muddy the waters
right of course you're losing but maybe
going something like this yeah now you
at least have a rook on the seventh and
both of the pairs of the Rooks are on
the board
you can try to make things a little bit
more complicated here you were worried
about me getting the bishop to F4 would
have been but F4 is defended I don't
really understand
in which situation you were concerned
about it F4 is defended by the pawn
if you were saying you were worried
about me playing F4
I get that but now look at these pawns
they're incredibly weak
white has rooked to E1 again you need to
look for tactics even with the Queens
off the board notice the alignment of
the bishop and the King what does that
alignment tell us it tells us that if
the E Pawn disappears from the board
black is going to lose the bishop so
after E3 there's Bishop takes E3
fe3 Rook E3 and the table's turn because
the bishop cannot be protected
so that's why I made the point about
preparing the move F4 before playing it
pawns don't move backwards that's why
it's a given that black has to advance
the king to the center before even
considering pushing these Pawns
so one piece of advice is that when
you're on the losing side of a position
like this
you can no longer afford the kinds of
niceties that you can afford when you're
better or when the position is equal you
can no longer afford uh to to you know
make prophylactic moves you need to get
on with business and you know obviously
you're not going to like the look of
anything but King B1 every Tempo is
precious when you're losing because
every Tempo with every Tempo that you're
not creating problems for your opponent
you're giving your opponent a chance to
consolidate does that make sense so
after King B1
when I look at this move
when I play A6 the game is over because
now I get the Rook to d8 you can't
really avoid a rook trade once the Rooks
are traded we just get our King to E6
um just to
reiterate that after Rook D7 check which
I would have played with white
we do not go King E6 that loses rookie
seven King D5 and Rook takes C5 these
types of tricks are no brandies you want
to set these types of traps if you're on
the defending side here
because it's not that obvious a lot of
people forget to look for tactics in the
end game
I think Bishop E3 is a little bit too
passive after H6
here we can basically stop our analysis
because F4 is coming and it's inevitable
maybe the last chance for white was to
go Rook D7 King F6 and now try to bring
the king into the game with King C1
of course G5 King D2 F4 is miserable but
white can try at least to force black to
work here a lot of people I think would
go F3
and F3 I think already is inaccurate
because now suddenly these pawns are
weak
if you're black here you want to be very
patient you want to play a move like H5
and the funny thing is if white pushes
the pawn on the king side a queen side
you can actually now play fg3 hg3 and
Bishop G3 creating a different set of
connected passers these ones are even
more dangerous than enf because they're
further away from White's King
so but still this would have given white
some practical chances bishop b3h6 and
G5 and the rest of the game is very
straightforward we just play up for him
trade and go E3 and we can stop here
any questions about this analysis a
simple straightforward game which was
made easier by the fact that Conrad you
you found a very interesting idea with
the pawn sack but practically speaking
to give up this Pawn is too big of an
investment given what you get in return
so it would have been you know much much
more challenging to defend the pawn of
the ship F4 it shows us that chess is
often about understanding the balance
the balance between
uh material and peace activity and
there's no clear you know the balance
sways in a different direction based on
certain factors the prevailing Factor
here was the was how easy it was for
black to create connected passers once
the pawn disappears from E5 if we
rearrange the pawn structure such that
if we just included the moves H5 H4 if
we had these moves already included and
we do exactly the same thing all right
we imagine that basically the same
position occurs on the board
already here after Bishop D4 I think
white is not worse
I think white is not or not much worse
because it is virtually impossible for
black to create connected passers so
that small of a change makes a huge
difference in the evaluation
and weighing these factors detecting
them
is a product of experience and analyzing
games and understanding when you
overestimate factors and underestimate
other factors in any case that's we're
going to end for today guys
hope you enjoyed the game
with white next game we're gonna insist
on getting something a little bit more
Tactical
and I'll see you guys later thanks for
hanging out today hope you enjoyed the
stream bye
[Music]